well I think the problem is that we have
to long ignored the possibility that
reality is stranger than we can suppose
I mean let this reverberate in your mind
not that that means no model will ever
work it means it will always be
provisional that the understanding of
what it is will always recede ahead of
any epistemic program to describe and
close explain this is all a fallacy if
you believe that you are embarked on a
finite project where eventually we will
issue a white paper and that will
explain how the Bohr ate the cabbage
it's not to be explained and we have I
think because of unique characteristics
of the male ego chosen to operate with
the assumption that we can understand
that the human mind can in fact grow
larger and larger levels of embeddedness
and make sense of them
and can't be understood it is a
receiving mystery it is a continuing
carrot it cannot be brought under the
aegis of rational apprehension it says
in Moby Dick reality outran apprehension
it always outruns apprehension because
apprehension is the primitive
functioning of the primate neural
network and reality who knows
who would even care to take a guess you
know
it's it's a mystery you do not measure
the depth of a universal mystery with
the neural network of a primate our role
is not to understand but to appreciate
to appreciate we have an immense
capacity for resonance with beauty
aesthetic awareness appreciation of form
appreciation of how things go together
it's ridiculous to attempt to seize the
tiller of reality because we don't even
know where we want to go so the notion
that by creating these models of reality
which are not acknowledged as modest but
which are called scientific truth we
betray ourselves down the primrose path
that leads to dreary dusty death because
what we do is we take the poetry out of
being we extract the poetry from being
by the assumption of the mundane
the banality of modernity is what I call
this the banality of modernity the
steady flattening of values so that
nothing means much you know the sense of
outrage over political mistreatment of
the underprivileged or the sense of
outrage of a society slips toward the
abyss or the sense of outrage when
people mistreat you is muted everything
is flattened by the banality of
modernity this is the heritage of all
the bad little boys of the 19th century
Nietzsche and Darwin and Hegel
Schopenhauer these clowns were on a bad
trip and they were loud about it and
what they give us is a universe devoid
of soul